jean michel vous avez fait un petit
portrait à et je crois que géraldine
vous avez la lettre que jean michel
maire ou à écrire
on va regarder le portrait de jean
michel maire assé l'amour est dans le
pré dont quelques instants dans 5
minutes sur m6 et juste avant regarder
le portrait de jean michel maire c'est
pour vous dire à guînes il vous aime
énormément regard
jean michel et chroniqueur dans une
émission médias cet ancien journaliste
de guerre au grand coeur est un
véritable amoureux de la nature
[Musique]
ce dandy est tombé il ya plus de temps
sous le charme d'une certaine gérald ans
la jeune femme a envahi sa vie la preuve
en découvrant la chambre de jean michel
voilà c'est mon petit chez moi mon petit
lit douillet n'aime pas trop les photos
de ma chérie voilà pour tous mes rêves
j'en ai partout je me suis sur ma table
de chevet voilà j'ai pas pu choisir même
dans ma table de chevet comme chaque
après midi jean michel travaille très
sérieusement pour l'émission du soir
[Musique]
et comme jean michel est un grand
romantique il prépare une lettre va me
pour ça
donc
géraldine en famille caisse
je me
nous
[Applaudissements]